Exactly. Like there's an adrenaline or like a dopamine hit that you get when you like reverse engineer something that you never understood before. And then it leads to like a bug.
And it freaking works.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Hey guys, our sponsor Project Discovery has dropped a new tool in collaboration with Google's own Mandiant team called TLD Finder. Okay, picture the sub finder, but for top level domains. Need I say any more? Check it out.
Alrighty, guys. Today we have Matt Brown with us. Matt, you look pretty close by two hours or so, right?
Yeah, just a little bit under two.
Nice, man. So he made the drive down to Richmond. Thanks for doing that. And we get to do a nice live in-person version of the pod, which I always look forward to. Those are always a good time.
And man, looking at this doc, I'm very excited. But we have to start at the very beginning, a very good place to start and get a little background about Matt Brown and how you became the hardware hacking specialist that you are.
Yeah, so my experience with cybersecurity and hacking started from a young age. I don't know. I just loved computers and playing around with them at first. And then I one day was at a bookstore and I actually brought my book from when I was 16 years old.
Look at this practical packet analysis. So so I bought this book and it was all about using Wireshark and examining all the packets that are flying across the network.
Do you check this out? They're analyzing HTTP in Wireshark.
Oh, yeah.
You know, like, oh, yeah, this is great. I love this.
There was a lot of clear text HTTP flying around back then.
And so I got that book and I was hooked. And so I was just running Wireshark and watching what kind of traffic my computer was generating and super interested in understanding like every packet, how it works, how TCP, UDP works, all that stuff.
And so that's kind of got me hooked. I also tried a little Wi-Fi hacking at home on my on my parents, a WEP.
Oh, my God.
WEP Wi-Fi network back in the day.
That was still a thing. So, yeah, I mean, obviously super easy, but you felt like this like hacker God when you could like run a program and have it print out the Wi-Fi password in a black terminal.
Right. Unbelievable, man. I remember the first time I cracked a web network.
Also my home network at the time. Yeah, man. What a rush.
Yeah. So so so following that, I went to college. I started as computer science, later transferred to MIS because I didn't want to take physics one and two or Calc three.
Dude, that those are so hard, man. So but you did CS. I would have assumed that you did like and computer engineering.
Right. Yeah. So I eventually came full circle to that in grad in grad school.
But in my undergrad, just got interested in general hacking and security.
We had an awesome information security student group at Iowa State, and they were talking my freshman year about all of these session tokens that would be flying around in clear text.
And I was also in my first programming class at the time, and it was a Java programming class.
So back in this would have been 2010. Back then, Facebook thought it was a good idea.
They had HTTPS on the login page, but nowhere else on the website.
Oh, my gosh. So and and later later on, no joke.
Facebook made it an optional feature. You could drill down into the settings of your Facebook account and optionally opt in to HTTPS everywhere.
No way. In the actual settings for that?
Yeah. On the settings for your account.
That's crazy. You could opt into this technology called Wow, dude.
You know, so at that point, there was session tokens and stuff like that flying around in plain text for Facebook.
They were flying around and on college campus at the time.
Encrypted Wi-Fi was not as popular.
So my gosh, you know, one in man, Wi-Fi, open Wi-Fi.
So literally flying through the air were session tokens.
And so I might have grabbed a couple of those from my friends.
Facebook browser, you know, sessions and pop their Facebook accounts.
Wow.
Pretty sure it's more than seven years ago.
That's a limitation.
Yeah, it's all gone.
So, wow, dude, that's crazy, man.
Yeah, it was the wild, wild west.
And I remember one of the first things I did in college was we had like a computer science 101 course and they were supposed to like have you.
You know, you're supposed to build something.
It was a very like abstract assignment.
They're like build something and like present it for everybody.
And we're like, okay, sure.
And so what we did was we built a system where we would get FTP credentials as they were coming over the wire.
And we demoed this whole like hack and, you know, this person would log with FTP and then the hacker would like grab it and that sort of thing.
And with man in the middle.
And our professor walks up to us afterwards and he's like, that was great.
You guys don't have to come to class for the rest of the semester.
And I'm like, oh, my gosh, I love you.
He's like a TA, you know, he's like a like a grad student, like a PhD student that was teaching this course.
So, yeah, lots of good times with that.
But the days and I actually thought that the days of, you know, seeing that sort of stuff, being able to to proxy and man in the middle and get all those tokens were gone.
But actually, we've got some some exciting stuff on the on the dock today about that.
So we'll swing back around to that.
So you're in college, you're stealing, you know, Facebook for your text credentials and that sort of thing.
Freshman year, sophomore year, they started to actually crack down on that.
But yeah.
And the other really cool thing we had at college were these cyber defense competitions where you'd be given about a month to prepare.
They give you a bunch of VMs with a bunch of holes in them, you know, purpose purposely put there.
Web apps vulnerable to all sorts of stuff.
And you had to go and secure those.
And then they brought in real world pen testers, professional pen testers to come and like test you for eight hours on a Saturday.
What was it?
What was those called?
Those competitions?
Because I competed in it as well.
But there's there's a few different levels of them.
Yeah.
So Iowa State does their own.
And I was at.
But there are a like national collegiate cyber defense competition.
I can't remember the name of it, but it was so it was so much fun, man, because the one we did, you could you could be on the offensive or you could be on the defensive.
So you've got to balance your time between hacking other people's stuff and securing your own stuff.
Oh, that's awesome.
And it was it was pretty cool.
It was really fun.
That was cool.
So, yeah, my experience at Iowa State is as an undergrad, I was on the defensive side.
You couldn't go hang out with the red team.
But in grad school, they let some of the grad students go and hang with the professional pen testers and be on the red team.
And that's where a lot of my offensive skills came from and my start to professional pen testing.
Well, it's cool because you get to work right alongside, you know, pro pen testers.
That's that's a really cool opportunity.
I'm glad to hear college was good for you with that.
I really for me, like my college experience was very much like trying to claw some some semblance of cybersecurity into my curriculum,
because the only piece of curriculum we had at the time for cybersecurity was this one course where it was all like theoretical cybersecurity.
They're like, you know, here's what this is, but no hands on nothing.
And so I went to the professor and I was like, please, like, let me do some labs every couple of weeks.
And she's like, sure, no problem.
Like and so we were able to do that and we got the cybersecurity club up and running and then we were able to get some good labs in place.
But it's good to hear that some universities, especially earlier on, too, where we're doing that at a good level and getting students into this sort of thing.
Yeah, no, that was a big thing.
Doug Doug Jacobson, he's the head of the information security department at Iowa State.
He was kind of on the forefront of that, you know, focusing on practical education.
Yeah.
For engineers, not so good.
Theoretical, you know, stuff, but actually hands on.
You know, at the end of the day, you know, college, it's kind of hard for the colleges to keep up with the pace of IT, you know, but at the end of the day, if you actually have your hands on something and you're actually doing something, you're going to get some semblance of experience.
Right.
It is, you know, rather than theoretical stuff.
So I would definitely rather have older material that is, you know, might be a little bit out of date, but it's hands on than cutting edge stuff and not hands on education.
I agree.
So not a whole fan of the whole college process anyway, but whatever.
Okay.
So, so fast forward.
I mean, do you jump right into red team stuff as you come out of college or how does that go?
Yeah.
So, so speaking of all those competitions, I also won a like forensics competition that like Lockheed Martin put on.
Oh, nice.
And that brought me to a job opportunity that was out in the Northern Virginia area here.
So that's what brought my family out here.
Mm-hmm.
It wasn't exactly the best job for me.
So I hopped around to some startups and, and, and then I got a job opportunity to actually move back into IoT hacking, which had always been a side passion project of mine.
But now I got to do it professionally, which was a pretty big blessing.
Wow.
That's awesome, man.
Okay.
And then fast forward a little bit.
We are, this is, our paths have not crossed to this point.
Yeah.
And then I go to this live hacking event in 2023 and, you know, Joel and I are hacking on a, on an IoT device.
We're crushing it.
We've got shells.
We're so pleased.
And then we show up to this event and it freaking, there's like rumors going around like Matt, Matt, Matt Brown, he's shells, you know, random reduction shells for days, you know?
And we're like, what's going on?
And, and you had so many bugs at that event, man.
You guys absolutely crushed it.
And so that was my first introduction to you there.
And you guys, you guys walked away with the MBH that time.
We did.
My first experience, this is probably not the normal bug bounty path, but my first ever submitted bugs were at the live hacking event.
Oh my gosh.
That I got the MBH at.
So that was an interesting introduction to bug bounty for sure.
You got plus one into that event.
I did.
Yeah.
So, uh, yeah.
Random deduction.
Uh, Jesse, she invited me on, uh, found me through my YouTube channel.
Nice.
So I know we've been talking a bunch about content creation.
Yeah.
So, uh, yeah, she found me through a YouTube video where I was, uh, doing some firmware attraction on an Amazon echo device.
Um, and that, yeah, so that happened to be related to, uh, the target of this event.
And so, uh, yeah, and, and this, this event was made for a hardware hacker, right?
Cause I think it was hacker one's first hardware only, or, or that was the majority of the scope for this event.
Yeah.
Definitely an event that was made for me, dude.
That was, that was very much.
So one of my favorite events that I've ever been to just because it's a different skillset for me.
And I got to also see Joel really shine in his area, you know, that he really loves.
So, um, yeah, what, what a great memory of that one.
And we definitely want to have random deduction Jesse on as well.
I've, I've talked to her a couple of times about coming on the pod, so we got to get that on the books.
Cause she's also got a tremendous amount of knowledge in, in a variety of areas.
Not even just, you know, IOT and hardware hacking stuff, but outside of that as well.
Um, so I guess clearly you had some experience with network pen testing from the competitions.
You, um, you know, did some practical packet analysis.
So we got some binary level stuff, you know, protocols, that sort of thing.
Um, what other pieces did you kind of pull together?
Because IOT hacking is such a challenging specialization because of the fact that
it's so broad, you know, you, you have to have some reverse engineering, you have to have some,
you know, networking experience.
You've got to have web stuff.
You've got to be able to do source code review, like all, and then hardware, you know, obviously
hardware, right.
Um, and so like, where, where did you get the web hacking skills and the, and the other components
that you need to be able to do the stuff you do today?
Yeah, that's a good question.
I think what makes me good at all this hardware stuff, and like you said, or, or hacking an
IOT system, cause it's not just the hardware device, right?
There's right.
You know, there, maybe there's a mobile app that controls it or, and then there's talking
web APIs and there's, there's all these different components.
And I just feel like over my time in technology, I've fought tooth and nail to, to try to be
as much of a generalist as I can.
Uh, and to understand a whole breadth of technologies and not be like, I'm the hardware only guy.
Cause there are some hardware security only people out there who are like finding bugs in
like Intel or AMD chips, right?
That's not how deep I go into the hardware side of things.
I like to understand the IOT system as a system where there is a embedded device, you know, with
code to reverse engineer that has network services that's communicating over the network.
So you have data in transit and, and, and, and stored, right?
And so it's a cool way for me to get, to keep learning about all these different technologies.
Cause I just love learning about technology.
I think that's what got me interested in this, uh, and computers at a young age,
cause there was kind of this limitless exploration you could do into the digital world.
All the various components.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, that, and that's, that's one of the things, you know, that we've, we've got here
as well on the schedule to talk about is like IOT hacking as a specialization,
I think is underrepresented in the bug bounty community.
I think it's really hard to find good hardware hackers that will go and hack on these programs.
Yeah.
Um, and I think one of the number one problems with it is in why it's not, there aren't more
people going down that path is, is really hard because you are constantly learning and you are
constantly, you know, having to use all of this information from all the various, um, different
disciplines of hacking.
Yeah.
Um, to attack the holistic system that is an IOT device, because there's going to be a user
interface, you know, there's going to be backend services that are listening.
There's going to be, you know, local privilege escalations, right?
You know, that sort of thing.
So there's, it's so expansive.
Um, but yeah, I guess, I guess that makes sense that it's really well fitted towards somebody who
wants to be a generalist or someone that wants to be a lifelong learner and always coming up against
stuff that they don't fully understand.
Yeah, no, no.
Some of the funnest, uh, bugs to find are when I have to develop a new skill.
Oh yeah.
In order to attack.
How rewarding is that?
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Like there's an adrenaline or like a dopamine hit that you get when you like reverse engineer
something that you never understood before and then it leads to like a bug.
And then it freaking works.
Yeah.
I love it.
I talked about this bug in, in my Defcon talk.
Um, and it was the first time that I'd ever like written a Python script from the spec to
exploit a binary protocol.
Oh yeah.
And I was like, and I was like, man, it just feels like I'm going to get some,
like something wrong here.
And of course, like I had to tweak in a couple of places, but eventually like within like an hour,
it was working.
Yeah.
And I was like, whoa, this is like, I added, this is not magic.
Like they actually just built it like the spec.
Yeah, man.
So, so rewarding.
Um, so yeah, I'm just looking at this list of, of, you know, cross, cross field knowledge that we,
that I had here.
And, and there's, there's so many, I mean, like we were talking about earlier today without
giving too much information away, but there's a mobile hacking component to do a lot of these
IOT devices because they'll be running off of like, um, you know, some bastardized version
of Android.
And they've got like all these like super weird APKs that have no UI and are just like,
a service running in the background, you know, all sorts of things on there.
Um, so there's a component to that too.
And then there's the hardware hacking piece, the web hacking, all of those.
So lots of, lots of really cool pieces that come into the whole IOT system.
Yeah.
I would say to, to that point and to somebody who is intimidated by, uh, you know, hacking on an IOT
target because of that, like you can bring your one expertise in one of those areas to bear on the
target.
And I think, I think I get to get into this in the doc, but, um, the hardware hacking skills,
all this super technical advanced stuff, you, it gives you more, uh, more attack surface to look at.
Right.
So you had Jason Haddix on and like to talk about the whole recon thing and how it just gives you
more stuff to hack on.
Right.
I love that you listen and can quote every episode of this podcast.
He's quoted like four or five episodes today, just in our like two hours of conversation.
So I think I'm caught up.
I think I've caught up on all the episodes.
So, um, there's, there's, there's, there's an interesting analogy.
It's not gonna be perfect, but in the hardware world, right?
The more you dig into the hardware, so like, I don't dig into the hardware for the hardware sake,
I dig into it to find bugs oftentimes in the, in the actual software running on the device or in a
mobile application that, or a, or a mobile API that is in this whole IOT system.
Yeah.
And like, like I think of it like,
It's recon, right?
It is recon for, for these IOT devices, for you to be able to understand what you're actually
working on, you know, cause at the end of the day,
the most impact is going to be some remote vulnerability, right?
Yeah.
That can allow you to pwn the, the, the IOT device.
Right.
And, and if it's a remote vulnerability, it's coming from some, you know, service that's sitting on that,
on that device that you can interact with.
And for that, you need to get your hands on what that software is.
Yeah.
And that's the goal of a lot of the hardware hacking piece, right?
Is to be able to get at that, uh, you know, internal firmware and understand what's happening
there a little bit better.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So like every IOT, uh, hacking exercise starts out as a black box assessment.
You have this device sitting in front of you, you know, nothing about it.
You can maybe like interact with some of the network services over the network,
but you don't really know what's going on inside the, the hardware hacking,
the firmware extraction, the getting a UART shell on the device.
Those are all tools.
That's going to turn that black box assessment a little bit more into a gray or a white box
assessment and get you access to more stuff to hack on.
Absolutely.
Okay.
So, so just talking about IOT hacking as a specialization again, you know, the first
problem that I mentioned, I wanted to bring a couple of these problems to you that I think present
themselves to hackers trying to get into IOT hacking as a specialization.
The first one of course was the breadth of knowledge that you needed.
Um, but the other one that I had here was how much upstart time there is
to find a vulnerability, right?
So me as a web guy, and I struggle with this all the time because of the concept of opportunity cost,
right?
Like, do I just log into a web application and start churning attack vectors, right?
On that web application and start churning out bugs, or do I spend for me, what often turns into be,
you know, 16, 24 hours of work hours, like working specifically on, uh, extracting the firmware,
getting my hands on like something.
So where I can actually start even testing these hardware devices, right?
Um, so I guess, how, how do you address that?
And how do you weigh the, I mean, obviously there's a lot of passion for IOT devices with you,
but how do you weigh the pros and cons of that?
And do you have any advice to hackers that are just coming up and starting to come into IOT hacking
on the, the, the cost of even getting started?
Yeah. So I guess the one thing is when you look at bounty tables, a good program is going to have
much more, uh, much higher bounty tables for the device category, then, you know, it's usually device,
mobile, uh, web is, is what you kind of see a tier system. Um, so there is more of an investment and,
and there's, there is a risk to your time, right? You're talking about that opportunity cost there,
there absolutely is. But oftentimes what I think you find at the, at the end of that exercise
is a lot of untouched scope because of that barrier to entry.
That's big.
So I like, like an analogy in the, in the mobile space is, you know, mobile APIs are not as tested
as much as your, your web APIs, because there's this barrier to entry of unpinning the app, right?
In an, in an even greater sense, there's this bear, there's a bigger barrier to entry in the hardware
world, but there's APIs that are that, that that device interacts with or services that run on the
device that no one has ever really assessed ever because maybe they had a pen test one time and the
pen tester like clicked scan against the IP of this system and like no, no real assessment with any
reverse engineering or understanding of what's going on.
So, wow. Sometimes these, these devices that make their way into bug bounty programs,
they could actually be completely unassessed.
They could, they could.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy, man. Yeah.
No, that makes sense. There's definitely a good amount of reward there. And I, I like what you said
about having higher hardware, um, bounty tables. I think that's really good. I think also, and this
is something we'll cover a little bit later on as well, but I think people coming from the web or mobile
world, you know, even talented hackers in those spaces have a hard time with attack vector ideation
for hardware devices, like what actually constitutes a vulnerability, you know, in a hardware device.
So I think that's, that's another challenging piece of it. So if you can nail that down, you
can start thinking, okay, well maybe I could get that, you know, 8K medium, you know, that there is
in the device world versus like a thousand, right. In the web world. Um, and so that, yeah, I think that
that is important.
I think you've said it on the podcast is like a full-time bug bounty. You're like, I'll report a low or a
I don't care, man.
I'll do that all day long. Like, especially when those bounty tables are advantageous for me.
Like a handful of mediums, I'm, I'm all in for that.
Yeah. You're, you're all set. I mean, you're, you're, you're out earning some crits on, on, uh, on
web scope oftentimes.
Yeah. And especially when you think about the CVSS, uh, I think I mentioned this in the doc, right? Like
as hardware hackers, a lot of times, yes, of course we'd love our attack to be remote, you know,
over the network. But a lot of the times we're sitting, uh, in that adjacent category. And so,
uh, it's sometimes hard to get the high or the crit you need, especially when those other categories,
Yeah, man, I haven't had a bunch of experience with CVSS scoring hardware vulnerabilities. I mean,
how does it do?
It is not as built out for the hardware scope. It, it just isn't. And the result of that good programs,
what a good bug bounty program will do is they'll say, yeah, yeah, yeah. We understand there's
this CVSS thing, but we understand the threat model of our device better and things that might have
technically been, you know, a high got called a crit or medium get called a high because they understand
the, the context that that device lives in. Um, I haven't had too many programs be super strict
about CVSS. They usually have their own internal, uh, rating system.
So I'm wondering how doing something like providing a initial research stipend for hardware hackers
would really, I think, I think for me, that would be an extremely motivating thing, right? So if like,
like a program comes on and says like, Hey, um, you know, we're, we're gonna be offering a thousand
dollars, you know, $2,000 to anybody who accepts the hardware devices and says, we're gonna give it a
shot. Right. Um, and I think these people have to be vetted, you know, hardware hackers, right?
They're people that are actually interested in hacking it or whatever. But I think that extra $2,000
would really help because that gives you a couple days of like, all right, well, you know, there goes
the opportunity cost problem that I had. And even at the end of those couple of days, I could write up my,
you know, approach to doing this so that the team, if they're really interested in securing it,
could actually put some, you know, blockers in place, like an encrypted partition or like, you know,
whatever. Um, and then, so there'd be benefit for them on that front as well. But then that also
solves some of the upstart problem for us. And then we can start zoning in a little bit more on,
on the actual hacking portion of that rather than just the setup, but also on the other side of this,
you know, Matt, I've seen some of your videos where you go from like zero to I have firmware in
like an hour and a half. Um, so I think maybe it could also be a skill issue, you know, on this side,
where it takes me like eight hours to 16 hours to actually like get firmware. Um, so I mean,
is that how often do you let me ask you that? Because you've you've assessed a ton of of hardware
devices? What what is your if you had to just sort of rough shot it? What is your average time to
um, firmware? Yeah, so I'm always going to go down a cascading, uh, list of steps that are more and
more extreme in nature to get at that firmware, right? Like, because first, if I can get a UART
shell on a device that gives me more than just firmware, because that gives me the ability to
debug the device while it is while it is running. And that has even more benefits that that allows me
to, you know, understand it makes it much more again, gray or white box of an assessment than that
completely black box assessment. Or if I'm just doing static firmware analysis, if I can't get that,
then I am going to go to that method of pulling a chip off of a device. And yeah, I guess that is
a thing that helps over time with experience that I've just pulled enough devices out of e-waste. I
mean, that's literally how I practice this stuff is I find devices out of e-waste Goodwill. Or if you
have a workplace that has a big e-waste bin, you just grab a bunch of devices and then you don't care
if you brick it, right? Right. You can practice, you know, uh, you know, de-soldering and soldering the
chip back on all day long. But you only get one shot though, too, if you just have one copy of it,
right? Like that's, that's the thing that I, that it gives me anxiety. Like, you know, I would love to,
I loved an event where they gave us like six of the devices. I was like six, this is great. I can brick
three of these and be totally fine. Like, I just felt so much more, um, emboldened at that event to
like try stuff and, and, you know, not be anxious about it, especially when these devices can be pretty
expensive. Um, but yeah, no, I think that's a great approach to like learn how to, you know, pull chips
off and stuff like that is doing the e-waste thing. That's, that's pretty solid. Yeah. And the,
and the other thing you get out of, uh, you know, targeting those devices or like older wifi routers,
you get off of eBay, you do get, uh, softer targets to, to look at, to kind of build up those hardware
reverse engineering exploitation skills that, uh, you know, if you're in a live hacking event,
the device is going to be a little bit more hardened than your average device that you pick up out of an
e-waste bin, right? Yeah, for sure. But it's, I mean, you still get surprised what you see sometimes,
like not naming any names, but there have been events where that has been really surprising to me.
Um, all right. So one last little problem with, with IoT hacking as a specialization that I want to
discuss was like, it costs a lot of money to get started in IoT hacking, right? Like, so this is
mostly oriented. This, this question is mostly oriented towards like, or for the, for the people
that are already experienced web or mobile hackers that want to also get into this space, right? Um,
you have to buy a ton of devices and a ton of like, um, equipment and, and all that sort of thing,
which can get pretty expensive on the, on just the upstart cost before you can even have a device to hack.
Um, do you think, what do you think is like the bare minimum setup and what are you doing with that
bare minimum set up to get started with, with the hardware hacking stuff, speaking to, you know,
an experienced mobile or web pen tester? Yeah. So I would say, yeah, there are tiers that you can
get into of like more advanced gear, but you do not need to start there, right? There are some basic
devices, uh, or sorry, equipment that you can get to get yourself started. And I go back to what I said
about IOT testing. It starts as black box and you can start an IOT assessment or, you know, bug bounty
hunting on a device without any of this hardware hacking gear. It's only going to get you more
insight into hacking the device. Um, but I would say the first thing, let me, you said, you said that
before and you've said that even off air before this, when we were talking, but I want to double
click into that a little bit. Like, what are you doing? Are you just like, and mapping it and like,
looking at the services and like playing around with the, if you're going to do a true black box
assessment like that without any hardware hacking stuff, like what would that look like?
So sometimes you'll find web interfaces, right? And so as a web hacker, you're like, oh,
hey, web interface just on an embedded device. I understand that. And, uh, it's just, it's just,
it's just a web server that might have command injection because they do sketchy stuff.
They do sketchy stuff. Yeah.
And maybe it's running as root. Who knows? You know? Uh, yeah.
I've never seen that before. Have you?
No, no, no, never. Yeah. That's why you, you mentioned, uh, privilege escalation. That
doesn't really happen very often in IOT. Cause if you get a shell, you're, you're just right.
You're, you're rude. It's impossible to do privilege escalation.
Oh my gosh.
Some of them are so immune because everything runs.
Everything just is rude. That's hilarious.
So, um, yeah. So you're, you're, you're hacking the, the, the web application. What else you got?
Yeah. So the other thing, it goes all back to my roots,
it's practical packet analysis. Data in transit. Right? Okay.
So not just targeting the system and what services it has, but what is that system
communicating over the internet to its cloud servers, to its APIs and stuff like that?
Is it shooting data over, over the network in clear text, HTTP? Like, like I mentioned,
like back in the day, back in the golden age of Facebook, uh, you know, account pwning, uh,
there are still IOT devices that will just blast data over the internet and clear text.
And so all sorts of consequences that you can have, uh, that will come from that. And then,
and then you take that data and you're learning more and more about, uh, about the device and
about the whole IOT system as a whole. Um, and then if it's encrypted, are they doing certificate
validation correctly? So all the, all the stuff that, uh, we're probably going to get into about cert,
about certificate validation in, in the TLS context or the SSL context that can all be done
in a completely black box test. You can have no access to the device and attempt to man in the
middle of the traffic. Oh, that is flying over the network. And then if you, if you see anything,
then you can start playing around with, okay, well I've got an access token here, or maybe I don't
even see any traffic here, but I see the SSL certificate, you know, host name or whatever.
Right. And I start playing around with that server. And that all gives you stuff to keep
in your notes. Cause then when you do get the firmware, the first thing you want to do,
if you see an SSL connection to a server, you're like, okay, I have a host name. Now can I go into
the firmware and find out where that request is being generated? What binary, what program is
creating that request? The find the request game. Yeah. I love that from Sam herb. Like, like that was one
of the, one of the pivotal moments for me collaborating with, with Sam herb was like, he's like, yeah,
whenever I'm reversing enterprise software, I always play the, can I find this request game where I,
where I see some request that comes through and then I, you know, I go into the, the software,
you know, that we've reverse engineered, whatever, figure out where that request originated from and
trace it all through. And that's the same thing we do there. Um, yeah, no, that, that, that makes sense.
I didn't even really think about the fact, so this is what I'm, what I'm talking about. Like just
understanding how the, the various attack perspectives, even for these, uh, IOT devices,
right? Because you have, you've got like, um, you've got a Jason network, right? You're on the
same land and you can, can you pwn it from there? Can you pwn it with physical access to the device?
Can you pwn it? Can you pwn the server that's, that's communicating with the device that, you know,
there is no user land thing even really like this is the device calling back to its, you know, home server.
Um, so there's lots of different perspectives from which you can Bluetooth. Yeah. Bluetooth again,
that adjacent network context that includes Bluetooth, wifi, uh, all of those types of
Yeah. So not even just land or like wifi related stuff, internet related stuff. Yeah. That's all
categorized in CVSS as adjacent networks. Yeah. Yeah. That, that all is really good scope to hammer on.
The Bluetooth stuff is really interesting too, man. I, I, I thought that it was going to be a lot more
complicated than it was when I took a look at it. Um, it, there, it is not that hard to get upstarted in that
with just like a mobile app that you can install on your phone and just write various properties
into this, you know, NRF, NRF connect. Yeah. Yeah. On any mobile phone, I, uh,
iOS or Android, although iOS has some weird permissions that it won't let you see the Mac
address of the device you're connecting with, but you can still like communicate with it. Yeah.
I it's iOS being iOS. Wait, really? Oh my gosh. Yeah. It'll show some weird you like you,
you UID or UID or whatever. Uh, it won't actually show you the Mac address of the device. They're like,
no, you are not allowed. Wow. You are not allowed.
Yeah. Freaking Apple, man. Classic Apple. Okay. So, um, I want the next section that I wanted to hop
into was this one regarding one of your recent videos, uh, decrypting SSL to Chinese cloud servers
that did really well, by the way, congratulations on that video doing so well. Um, and one of the things
you cover in that is exactly what you were just talking about a moment ago of bumping SSL on these
IOT devices and, um, you know, getting access to the communications from that, that device,
calling home, sending data out the back door, that sort of thing. Um, so for me, the way that I
understood how that would work normally was I need something like a wifi pineapple or some malicious
router device that I can use to, um, you know, make this router connect to that router, right?
Yeah. Or whatever. And, and send the traffic through that and then, you know, have it come back
to my computer or whatever. And that scared me a little bit because it's a lot of like, all right,
now I gotta get a malicious router and I gotta set all that up. But when I looked at the way you did
it in this video, it was freaking beautiful, man. There's like a, like a 15 line config file that you
wrote that does everything. And it was just awesome. So could you talk a little bit about that methodology
and what kind of equipment slash setup you need to do something like that? Absolutely. So yeah,
that tool on GitHub is called man in the middle router. It's all it's doing is it's, you know,
duct taping together a few different open source Linux utilities that when they're brought together
are going to effectively do the same thing a wifi pineapple is going to do. It's going to set up an
access point with whatever SSID password encryption type you want. And then it's going to, and then
optionally my program, you can also have like a USB to ethernet dongle. So if you have an ethernet
based device, it can feed into this same network. Yeah. That's kind of the way that I thought that you
would do it was you would just take like an ethernet cable and put it on the WAN port of
your router or whatever, if you're attacking a router and have that go through something.
When you're attacking routers, is that normally the way you do it? Or do you like link one router
to the other somehow? Yeah. So, so with this, with this manual router program, it's actually
making my Linux computer into a router, a router by kind of, again, it's kind of cobbling together a
router, but because basically all that a router does, I mean, it does some other things, right? But
the bare minimum that a router needs, it needs to, you know, spin up a Wi-Fi hotspot, right? So we
can do that with host APD. Okay. And all your Wi-Fi routers, 95% of them are doing that under the
hood anyway, just with some web GUI or a mobile app that controls it. Which you figure out once
you've shelled enough of them. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're like, where's the host APD file and the SSID
and password that's clear text on the device. Lovely. So there's that. And then we have some IP tables
rules that are going to like pass the traffic that are going to forward the traffic out to whatever
your WAN interfaces. And in the context of my program, the WAN interface means whatever interface
on your computer has internet already, right? So you could be connected to Wi-Fi, ethernet, whatever,
on the upstream side. And then optionally, I have a bunch of IP tables rules that can take traffic
that's egressing out of there and say, No, no, no, don't go out, come over to my my TLS proxy,
that's going to man in the middle all that traffic. And so in that place of that proxy program,
you can run any number of things. So, so birth suite can run in transparent mode. So you need
a transparent proxy, right? So you can use Kaido, but you have to put something else in front of it,
like man in the middle proxy, so you can have man in the middle proxy, which is a transparent proxy
and use Kaido as an upstream. Or this new tool that a researcher named Apo gave a DEF CON talk on,
which is called CertMidum. And the advantage to this CertMidum tool is that it will, it will try to
intercept the requests with a number of different tests. So like, let's say that the IoT device was
merely checking that your cert was signed by a CA authority that it trusts and trusted, but it
didn't check the name, the CN, the common name of the certificate. So if you had a cert like attacker.nmat.com
that was signed by Let's Encrypt and that device trust, trust Let's Encrypt, well, then he's got a test
for that where you can load in your Let's Encrypt sign cert and then it will, it will perform these
tests, but it will perform all the tests. And then the other really cool thing is tool does is if it
fails, if it fails to intercept, right? If the device is properly performing certificate validation,
it will then let it pass through because what you'll find a lot of time on an IoT device is maybe
the device will get make request one, it'll get a response, it'll parse it, and then it'll make
request two. And then you know, same thing in the request three, but maybe it's only request three
that has a certificate validation issue. Well, if you're just black, if you're if you're just doing
this attack over and over again on the first request, the IoT device is never going to move through
to that state where it's making that request. Yeah, because there's lots of different I mean,
it seemed how when I was reviewing this talk, I was amazed because this is essentially like,
like access control, like in my web brain says, this is access control validation for SSL, you know,
essentially, there, there's so many things you would just assume that I don't know why I would assume
this because it's such a terrible thing to assume, but that you know, something at that lower level is,
is going through all the checks and like, you know, is sticking to the spec or whatever. But that's
never what we've seen ever in the history of security. It's quite the opposite. It's just so smart to look
at all these edge cases, you know, you can really when you watch the video, you can see how he is
intimately familiar with TLS and familiar with all of the different spots along the way where,
you know, edges could be cut, you know, corners could be cut, and you're not actually, you know,
doing the full validation. And then he built this into this super easy to use tool. So I'll definitely
be using that I think in the future for this sort of thing, because if you can, I mean, if you can bump
SSL on those sort of things, I mean, it's very impactful to be able to see what is actually
happening between the device and the call home server, there's so much weird shit that happens
there that they never expect you to see. Exactly. Ever. You know? Yeah. And again, it's all this
untouched scope, a lot of the times. Yeah, the piece that you mentioned about it passing through
is so brilliant as well, because they abuse the retry, you know, parts of TLS where they're like,
okay, something funky happened that time, let's just retry it, right? Yeah. So he's like, do
something funky, do something funky. Most of the time, they don't like it if I do it more than like
three or four times. So I'm gonna let them through on this one, but I'm gonna get them on the next one.
You know, it was very, it was very well built. I've got in here the various lists of, of, you know,
attacks that they do with this software. Very cool. Shout out also to Lupin, who, who brought this to me.
When it was first released, it was like, dude, this is crazy. Like, all of these mobile apps are
like not doing any validation at all. And, and I was like, Oh, okay, cool. Lupin, you know, I didn't,
I never went back to it until I watched this video. And I was like, Oh, of course, like IoT,
man in the middle, and this makes so much sense. So yeah, Lupin, you, you, you, you were early on that,
man, you rocked it. Okay, so we've got, okay, so just coming back to your, your router thing really quick.
You've got this beautiful, like, I mean, the things like 15 lines, but it spins up a DNS mask,
you know, thing to deal with DHCP. And then you've got the
That's the part I left out about what you need in a router, you need a DHCP server, because
who does static IPs nowadays?
Right, exactly. So you've got your DHCP, three lines of DNS mask,
config, you've got your host APD, like 10 lines of config. I just wanted to just give you a public
shout out here on this, because this shows true understanding and true mastery of these things,
when you're able to make it this bare bones in the simple, right? Because as hackers,
the more complexity we have, the more like noise that we have, it prevents us from seeing the edge
cases and the, the, the what's truly being happening, you know, behind the scenes, right? So when you have
something so simple, and beautiful, that just routes everything through, it just makes me so happy.
So when I saw this, I was really, really excited. And I think that this reduces a lot of the friction
needed to start man in the middling these IoT devices. So thank you so much for that. And then
I just want to clarify some of the requirements for this. So obviously, you need a Linux device,
right? Whether that's going to be a Linux desktop or a laptop, you probably need something dual booted.
So it's like actually at the OS level. Yeah, you could you could in theory, do this on a VM,
you just needed a USB pass through. Yeah, yeah, I need to figure out how to do this with, with WSL,
because I've switched to WSL. And it's a little bit dicey, man, like, yeah, no, no promises on WSL.
It seriously, and it works so well, like 90% of the time. But there's just like that little extra bit
that I'm like, Ah, wouldn't it be really cool if I could do this. But this is neat, really needs to be
native Linux sort of thing. So I do miss my my, my dual booted computer for that. So
I will say as a hardware hacker, yeah, being native on Linux, it just, it makes it makes sense for me,
because that's where I live. Most of the devices I'm targeting, if they're not a microcontroller,
they are Linux based or some Android, you know, derivative. Your videos are really good too. What
are you using for your like, window manager within Linux? Oh, yeah. So so I run Arch Linux like a crazy
person. Yeah, I run running Arch Linux over here. By the way.
And I run i3, which is a like a tiling window manager. Solid. I'm basically a complete Linux
snob. Yeah. When it comes to all that stuff. When you said Arch and i3, I was like, okay,
yup. Get off my podcast. Okay, and the other things you need, I mean, do you need any sort of special
wireless card for this? Like, I feel like this is not something you can do normally. In theory, you don't,
but in practice, you might want one. Laptop Wi Fi drivers, I have experienced this with the poor
triagers who have had to triage my bugs that involve Wi Fi. I'm sorry for that. It's who knows what your
Wi Fi driver what capabilities it will have and won't have on Linux. And so what I like to use always
for the Wi Fi just for consistent experience is a good alpha. So alpha makes USB wireless cards,
and you want to get one. And again, Linux Wi Fi is a pain. You want to get one with a MediaTek driver.
So I can I can give you a link to leave in the show notes if you want a good suggestion.
I see these. Yeah, I've seen these before. Yeah. So alpha A L F A. Yeah, so those are pretty much
like the hacker go to go to and if you have a MediaTek, you know, chipset, it will work out of the
box on pretty pretty much any Linux distro. And because you need different capabilities, depending on
which attack you're doing for this setup from the man in the middle router setup, you just need to be
able to put it into master mode, which is like AP mode in Linux. But if you want to do Wi Fi hacking,
then you might want to do things like have packet injection where you can spoof the Mac address that
it's sending as yeah, it's like that. So there are different attacks and though that adapter is going
to pretty versatile, you use going to be a used for any of that stuff. So you, you had also here on the
sort of list of requirements for this a USB to ethernet adapter. And I'm wondering why you you do
that because I feel like you can just use your ethernet port oftentimes to be able to, you could
use it you can use your onboard ethernet if you aren't already using that for sure for your
wireless card. Yeah, I'm yeah, so I'm usually like sitting at my at my desk at home and I have
ethernet just as more reliable. And so my upstream internet will be taking up the ethernet. Gotcha.
So you want to have another one? Yeah, that makes sense. Very cool, man. Yeah, no, that's, there's
lots of lots of uses for all this stuff as well. You know, lots of ways you can apply it. So I think
it's I think it's worth the investment for me to grab one of these alpha cards just for consistency as
well. And I'll keep that in mind. You said it was media tech drivers, media check drivers are much better
on Linux. Yeah, you'll have all sorts of problems with other wireless drivers. It's one of those things on
Linux. It's Yeah, I appreciate that you speak to that. Because whenever you get those sort of
incompatibilities, I think those are the times when I've been the most frustrated in my entire life,
is when I've got something like a driver, like some device that just won't freaking work between like,
freaking Ubuntu, you know, it's like, this is like the most popular Linux distro. Like, how am I having
this problem? Right? And, and I think there have been times where I've literally spent multiple days
trying to deal with just set up issues like that. Yeah. And I just have to walk away. I don't ever
get that frustrated. No, no, and it definitely drives people away from the Linux community. But
yeah, it does. What are you gonna do? Yeah, you got to figure it out, you know, and then what I think
once you get a better understanding of some of these things, you go through that trial by fire,
it becomes a lot more doable. And I haven't run into issues like that in a couple years. I'm really
grateful for that. Because it's it's a pain in the ass. Sometimes for me, it's actually, a lot of times,
it's, it's dual booting stuff. I'll get myself into a pickle with like grub. And like, trying to get
things to like, I just I just hate it. Windows and it'll like, man, it'll be like grub, you don't
need this. Yeah, like, what is that? I am the only operator. Yeah, clearly, you don't use Windows. Come
on. Yeah. All right, man. Um, yeah, I think for any of you, is just I'll just shout to the audience
real quick. For any of you that haven't seen this video decrypting SSL to Chinese cloud servers.
You know, it's really, you know, it's a very niche thing that he's working on here. But I think a lot
of the principles are very widely applicable to IoT hacking. So if you're looking to men in the middle,
these devices, I think this is a really cool video for that. So we'll link that down in the description
as well. Definitely check that out. The next section that I wanted to move on to was the general IoT
hacking methodology. I've been holding off asking you questions today as we've been hanging out a little
bit before this episode. But I'm really excited to dive into this. So when you are approaching a
device, obviously, you've got your ways of getting a shell on the device prior to pulling the chip off,
right? You've got your you are you've got J tag. You got like glitching into those two things,
right? Yeah. And so I'm wondering what, what time? What do you try before you switch to a chip off
methodology? And, and, you know, effectively break your device there. But we'll come back to that
because there are some nuances. Yeah, yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. So so you are is always going to be my
first goal on any device. I guess we got to talk about devices in two different categories, because
one, there's a microcontroller, a microcontroller based device, and then a more like a rich OS like
Linux or Android or something like that. And so I treat those two very differently in my process,
a microcontroller. If you if you found the lucky device that they didn't disable J tag on,
then you can use J tag to dump the firmware. And that is the way to dump the firmware. And then if
J tag is locked, then glitching is the way to glitch the system into unlocking J tag or or the read it,
whatever readout, you know, protocol is being used. So but that methodology, I am not
experienced with I tend to favor and target the Linux based devices a lot more glitching is
something I want to learn and get into more. Yeah, it's a very advanced skill. And kind of like I
talked about how there's people who just focus on like hardware security. There are people who
like everything they do is glitching chips. Yeah, and pulling firmware off of them. So reverse
engineering. So when you're when you're talking about microcontrollers versus, I guess, microcomputers,
or like micro actual, you know, Linux systems. Yes. Yeah, I mean, on some of these boards, there
there may not even be a core OS for you to get very much off of, right? It's just like a board,
you know, with with its own firmware attached to it, they're not running a, you know, an op,
a very minimized version of Linux, like which is what we often see. And then you know, even further,
there's like, okay, you're actually running like a stripped down version of Android or whatever.
Yeah, that's a good differentiation. I like that. I will say in the microcontroller case,
I might even tend to jump to chip off faster if and this is a big if so microcontrollers have built
in flash pretty much all of them do. Yeah, but they optionally can have external flash. And so if it's
external flash, then it's just a flash chip like any other flash chip, you can pull it off, pop it in
your universal programmer and you can read that that that firmware out. So I've never hacked a micro
controller. I've always hacked microcomputers, you know, stripped down Linux versions or whatever.
Yeah. So when you're dealing with a microcontroller, what kind of stuff can you expect to get off?
Not very much, not very much without, again, very involved reverse engineering, which,
again, being really honest, like in a bug bounty context where you are considering ROI,
like time, money, like, like, is this going to pay off? It might not. It might not. There is a case,
though, there are always exceptions to these rules, because I believe the bug of mine that we're going
to talk about that has performed on a microcontroller. So occasionally you can find files or something
like that. But what you're going to be looking at the firmware is going to be a binary blob. Because
if you think about what a microcontroller is, again, I'm from the Linux world. Right. So I think of
everything through that lens. So how I like to think of a microcontroller is it's one static program.
Like think if there was only one process, you know, binary. Exactly. And when you boot up the processor,
it starts the program. And when that program exits, the CPU halts. Wow. Like like that. And so and so
that's why, you know, when you're coding microcontroller, you have like an infinite loop. Right. And then you,
you know, you call various threads or do your stuff. But it's always running. So hard for me to think
about that even like, yeah, I so think about that whole ecosystem from a Linux and OS perspective as
well. And you think that there's this thing called a file system, which sometimes they build in.
Sometimes there are these microprocessor OS is, you know, where they will build out the concept of a
file system that can exist on a microcontroller. But most of the time, that's not saying geez, dude,
that's crazy. So a lot of this stuff is just getting held in in memory. And yeah, yeah. But if you can,
if you can extract that firmware, and you see things like secrets or certificates, like,
right, like, like, we'll find talking about in our finding down the road, you can maybe do something
with that. Maybe you can do firmware modification. Maybe you can grab those secrets. And then,
or URLs, right? If you see API endpoints, any kind of clear text string, you're going to look at that.
Strings is your friend there, right? DD and strings is your friend there.
People ask me all the time, like, oh, you're this like, really advanced, like IoT hacker. How do you
find that password in that program? Did you reverse your journey? I ran strings.
Like half the time, literally, the first thing I do, if I get a binary blob, I run strings, pipe it into less,
and then I just hit the down page button on my keyboard.
What are you what are you doing with less, man? You got to pipe it into a Vim buffer.
And then it like, oh, geez, what are we doing?
I know. Oh, my gosh. Okay, so, so very good differentiation. I'm really glad you you brought
that up. Because there, those are definitely two different worlds, right?
Yeah, so back to the Linux path, because I think this is where some of these skills really come into
use more. So, so my first goal is UART, because UART gives me more than just the firmware, if I if I get a
good UART shell. So when you connect, when you find your UART interface, right, UART is a serial
protocol that allows you to communicate over, you know, you know, some some volt, some digital signal
over a voltage, you know, maybe usually 3.3 volts. So you connect up your cable. So we go back to what
equipment do you need? My first piece of hardware hacking equipment I would ever suggest is a multimeter
and a 3.3 volt UART to USB cable. Yeah, that is going to help you get so much on so many devices
that the ROI on that is just incredible. That seems that seems and it's like a $15
cable. And it's pretty universal to you know, any hardware hacker that I've talked to is like,
yeah, man, just get a multimeter in a in a UART cable. And you know, you're you're good,
a very large portion of the time. Yeah, like identifying maybe a soldering iron,
because sometimes they take the they don't populate the pins and the production devices. So you
have to put a little you know, like, you know, half a cent pin and soldered on but yeah,
yeah. So so when you're identifying UART, are you often doing that from the data sheet? Are you just
kind of like poking around on the on the device with the multimeter? Are you I mean, obviously,
you you know, after a little while, you kind of get a trained eye for it, you can say, Okay,
that's like four to six pins or whatever right there. And it's four to six, right? No, it can be
It depends. But if you see two things that look like connectors on the board, the one with more
pins is J tag one less is you are. But yeah, it's all it's all pattern recognition. Like I can just
look at a board and be like, Okay, there's the flash, there's the RAM, there's the CPU, you know,
over time, you do get that trained eye. And that's why I really always suggest people go dig through e
waste. And just like, open up devices, even if you just open up the device and look at it,
you're gaining something because you're looking and you identify the components on the board. Yeah,
because you're you're getting those reps in to be like, Okay, there's you are. There's the flash
chip. Those are the things that I care about. This is the same thing we tell new web hackers is you
don't even have to hack anything, you don't have to try anything, just get start looking at HTTP
requests as they come through the proxy and start understanding what that does as as correlated to the
action that you just performed in the web browser, right? If you can categorize those requests and start
understanding, okay, anything century related, you know, or whatever, like that's that's metrics,
I don't need to look at that super much. It's funny, because that contradicts what I said last week about
about century being an interesting attack surface, which it is. But you see, you know, if you're
not for the new hackers,
Yeah, exactly. If you're a new hacker, you want to, you know, zone right in on the functional API
that's that's targeting the main website, right? And I think this is the hardware version of that of like,
break these break these things open, start identifying all the various components.
Know that's a flash chip. Know that might be a UART connector, you know, that sort of thing.
Exactly, exactly. Yeah, yeah, the things I'm looking for on a board are UART and the flash chip.
That's it. On a Linux based system, I'm not really worried about JTAG at all. Honestly,
I'm just kind of leaving that by the wayside. With UART, then I'm then I'm go if I if I if I see something
that I think is UART, I'm turning on that device, I'm probing with my multimeter with ground, I find
ground somewhere, Wi Fi antennas are always ground, you find you find shields that are grounded. And
I'm probing the pins to find a voltage that fluctuates, especially on boot. And that's probably
the transmit pin. And then usually next door to that pin, to the right or the left, I found weird
devices where it's somewhere else, you'll find the receipt, you'll find the receive pins. Yeah,
where you from your UART cable are going to transmit to it. So you've got transmit,
you've got receive, you've got some voltage one, what is it? What is that? So you don't need VCC.
Yeah, VCC. That's only if you're going to be powering the device over the UART cable,
which usually doesn't work anyway. Sure. You actually want to just completely ignore that.
Yeah. And sometimes I think people have been like, don't mess with that port because it'll blow your
if you hook it up to the wrong thing, it'll like, screw your USB port on your laptop.
It might do something bad. Yeah. Just, just, just leave it alone.
Don't touch that, Justin, is what I've heard. Okay, cool. So you identify that,
you give that a shot. That doesn't work. JTAG is disabled. You could go the glitching route,
but more often we're going to go the chip off route. Exactly.
And so that process, as far as I look, as I know about it, and maybe you can sort of walk me through
that is, um, you get like a hot air station and you are, you know, fluxing this thing up,
the, the flash chip, you have to identify the flash chip first, right? Yep. You're,
you're hitting it with hot air until you're able to pull it off. Right.
Yes. And then you're cleaning the chip off, getting it in good shape, putting it into a chip reader.
Yeah. Um, and then hopefully you'll be able to just read that chip, just like the actual system would,
as it's booting up. And then you can, you know, access all the various partitions and file structures
that they have on that device. Um, how often is it that simple?
It's, I would say it is usually that simple, assuming that you have the right reader. So
almost like step zero in that process before I ever shoot hot air. And I talk about this on my videos,
it's just like, read the serial number on the chip and make sure you have the right device,
like to take it off. Cause especially in the context, right, where, uh,
you are new and starting out. You don't want it. You don't want to unnecessarily brick a device
because you pulled the chip off and you're like, Oh, well I don't have a reader for this now. And
I gotta go order one from China or whatever. It's going to take two weeks. Yeah. It's going to take
a long time to get here. Um, yeah. So I would identify, I always read the chip serial or, you know,
the, the, the identify the model number I go and I look in my software. So the chip reader I use for
everything that's not EMMC based stuff is going to be the X Geku, uh, T 56. That is a universal
programmer. It's got tons of different sockets that it can, uh, can fit into it. It actually does do,
uh, EMC chips now. Um, yeah, I was going to say, so if you're not talking about any EMC chip,
what is, is this like a flash chip that you're, what is this other alternative? I don't really hacked EMC.
Yeah. So EMC is only on like high end Android devices or like, yeah, it's, it's, it's usually
where you're going to have more storage on board the system. Uh, cheaper IOT devices are going to have
a NAND flash chips or even spy flash, um, which are just slower. Right. Um, and, uh, usually don't
have as much capacity. Yeah. I mean, they can EMC chips, they kind of hook up. I mean, you can almost,
I've seen some, some people mentioned that you can kind of wire them into an SD card reader,
itself. Like you can literally connect the, some of the, the pieces on the, the, um, what are they
to call the plates or whatever on those directly into a USB to micro USB converter and it'll read
like an SD card. It, it, it, it like, it like fundamentally is an SD card in a different shape.
So cool. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So that, that, that's pretty cool about that. Um, and then there's this
new kind of chip, uh, called UFS, which it looks exactly like EMC, but your normal EMC reader
can't read it. So I ran into that before. Um, that's tricky, but those, uh, I've got,
I've got another reader for that. But again, I'd say this ex Geku platform is, I mean, it's got some
sketchy like Chinese software that you have to run in windows or I run it under wine. Cause I'm,
you know, I like to stay in Linux. Right. Okay. Yeah. Um, but I, uh, yeah, I'm, I'm a snob.
I, it's okay. I'll own it. Um, I, I like that programmer because it does the, the widest amount
of type of types of chips out there. And I just have to get one device. I have to buy new sockets
occasionally to fit different chips and stuff like that. Cause there's like, there's like little
molds or whatever, right. The, you, or at least this is my experience with that, with the, um,
EMC chips where, you know, you have to get it in a specific mold and then you put it in there and
that aligns everything properly so it can read up through those, those, uh, those ports. Um,
yeah, that's, I mean, you need, you need some specialized stuff for that. So yeah.
Yeah. So in the, in the like, you know, electrical engineering world, it's called the package. So
the package type defines like the shape, it defines the geometry of the, of, of the chip. And then EMC is
even weirder cause you'll have the same pin out on the bottom, but there'll be different dimensions of
the chip. And then, so you'll have these different like guiding rails that you put into your
EMC reader. Yeah. Yeah. That's what I'm talking about. Okay. And so in the nan,
you know, nan flash world or it are those other things you actually have to have the, the, the
layout of the pins is different on the bottom. And so you actually have to have specialized adapters
for that or. Yeah. So the universal programmer, it has basically a set interface and then it has
different sockets that all fit this one common interface. And so the software inside this universal
programmer is smart enough to know, like you configure the software. So instead of like the EMC reader
where you can just like, it just can mount onto your, onto your Linux computer, like, like, like,
it's a mass storage device or an SD card, right? Yeah.
These other types of reads, you have to read it out to the software and it literally just gives you
the firmware file. Okay. And it's not partitioned. So you have to go through there and use bin,
usually you can use bin walk and it'll just, it'll just extract the file. Okay. Gotcha. So you're
getting just a big blob out of that. Um, and then you're, you're, you're not actually looking at a
whole file system or whatever. You're having to extract that file system and bin walk can get
messy sometimes too, man. It can, it can. There's another, there's another tool called un blob.
I, I, I swear every, every like six months I like, you know, will like curse bin walk and be like,
I need to just not do anything else for like, you know, like for like at least a quarter and just like
program a new tool that does it. A new bin walk. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Dude, it's probably so much harder than we think it is. It is. It is. I'm so sorry. Like
you are amazing. Yeah, they are. They're awesome. Um, that's great. That's great. Okay. So,
so we go down that process, we do the chip off, we load it up into our reader. We get either,
you know, this, this big blob and we've been walked it, extract the file system,
or we just mount it like an SD card and read off all the various partitions or whatever. Yeah. Um,
we look around, we identify the main partition. We start, you know, we, we can, we can mount it,
just CD into it, start playing around, start reading all these config files, grabbing for secrets,
getting our hands on source code, hopefully. Um, and, and, uh, so once we do that, are you like,
where do you go post exploitation? Most of the time, are you looking at like network services? Are you
looking at the way that that device communicates back up to the, the, you know, home, the mother server,
whatever, you know, like, you know, that's running this fleet of IoT devices. Um, what is your go-to
approach from there? Yeah. So it's definitely contextualized based on the IoT device, but I'd
say those are my two approaches, right? It's what network services are available on the device and,
uh, what communications again, again, again, like, like data in transit. I love looking at and
understanding data in transit. And if they're so, okay, so if, if I have a device where it is doing
all the SSL verification correctly, and I haven't yet been able to peek inside of that traffic, I can
either statically analyze the firmware to understand what types of requests can be made to those cloud
servers. Or if I've got the skills to reattach the chip, I can patch in my own CA certificate, and then I
can put the chip back on and now it trusts my certificate. Uh, and, and now I can, now I can use
man and mill proxy. I can use whatever one of those transparent proxies to intercept the team.
We're going to, we're going to talk about the BGA reballing and that chip remounting later. So we'll, we'll, we'll
hold that for now. But yeah, but that applies to any kind of chip. Yeah. That's not applied to any kind
of chip, which is way easier when it's not BGA, right? So really, okay, think, think a spy flash
chip just has eight, uh, legs. It just has eight legs. Yeah. It doesn't have 153, you know, pin pads
at the bottom and the legs are exposed on the sides of the chip. So these are probably like the easiest
to solder. I was going to say, so you don't even need a hot air gun. You could, you could just one at a
time with a soldering iron reattach. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You could, you could do that to put it back.
I've actually seen some hackers get like these little mini clips that they use to like clip onto
those legs. And then you can just essentially like, cause it's just electrical signals going
over that, you know, reading out of there. So when it boots up, you could just swoop and just slurp up
the data. Yeah. So you can do that. I love my, I love my, my technical hacker, uh, you know,
sound that I may, uh, no, that's great. That's awesome. So those clips, there's some pros and
cons of those. So obviously if it works, the pro is you didn't have to desolder the chip off the
board and you still have a functional device, right? Right. The con is that sometimes, uh,
when you're doing that read, it, it actually is sending power from your reader and it's trying to,
cause it is powering on the chip. And sometimes it can like inadvertently power on different circuits,
but in an unexpected way. And it just won't either, either won't work. I mean,
in really rare cases, you might blow something, but that probably not. Um, and also sometimes where
you just have to chip off it. Yeah. The equipment is, is pretty expensive, I think for that too. So
I think the, um, yeah, especially when it's simple and you've got like, you know, eight points that you
need to solder back on. Yeah. It may not be that bad about you. Just pull it off and then resolder it
back on afterwards. Yeah. Especially once you get a little bit more familiar with how to do this
soldering thing. Cause for me, I mean, the only soldering experience that I, that I have, um,
is getting essentially soldering on those little connectors so you can connect up to you art or
whatever. Right. Yeah. And, uh, and so I think that's a little bit more intimidating to me,
but, but I think, uh, I think that would be a fun one. Flux is the magic.
Flux is the key, man. Of all the reattachment, right? Flux is just this magical substance that makes the
solder go where it's supposed to go. I think every hardware hacker has like this amazing image of
flux. Everyone's like, man, they'll just sit down and I'll be like, Hey guys, let's talk about
hardware hacking. They're like, have you ever heard of flux? Flux is the shit dude. Like it just makes
everything. I'm like, okay, listen guys. Like, can we move along from the flux please? Um,
it's so funny, dude. Uh, okay. So I guess I'm gonna, I'm gonna push you again on that last question
though. So if you had to pick one or the other, let's say it is a, it is a call home device. So
there is some sort of cloud management. Um, are you first going to go after the network service?
Are you going to go after the call home stuff? I think this goes back to how I think I, I am always
interested in data and transit. And so I'm always going to look at that traffic going out and trying to,
understand those APIs. Sure. I think that's where the impact is too, you know, cause if you can pop
something up in the cloud, then you can pwn all the devices. Exactly. Imagine, imagine if there's
like the, in the, in those call home API requests, there's an IDOR and now you can, now you can make a
request on behalf of any device. Imagine that. Yeah. I know, right. There would be an IDOR in those devices.
I know. Yeah. Yeah. So that you're right. That's where the bigger impact can lie. And so that's
where I want to target first. But the network services, I mean, again, I'm, I'm going to be
doing all of these in my assessment and going down every track. Once you, once you get firmware,
how important is it to you to get a dynamic shell? Like, so you can do dynamic analysis
of what's happening on the device. It's moderately important. I can totally, you know, do static
reverse engineering all day. I like doing, you know, static analysis. I actually really rarely
will connect up GDB, but RCE isn't my best Vaughn class actually that I'm the best at. So
I'm better at like reverse engineering, weird binary protocols. I don't know. Like I said,
I get that. I get, I get the dopamine rush from when the only thing standing in between you and act
absolutely pwning something is understanding how the stupid protocol is. Custom protocol that some
engineer invented out of whole cloth, right? Yeah. Rolled, rolled their own crypto and everything
into it. It's like, Oh my God. Yeah. That, that makes sense. Okay. So, so
not only important to get a shell, but it does help. It has huge benefits, right? Because sometimes
you'll be rever, you'll be doing your static analysis and you'll be like, I just don't understand.
Or maybe, you know, Ghidra or whatever other reverse engineering binary reversing tool is giving you
a pain in one spot. And if you can just log into that shell and see what's actually going on on the
device, like, Oh, it's writing a file here, but I don't really understand what the file contents look
like. I could spend eight hours reverse engineering the static binary to figure out what it's writing
into that file or you can just go log into the shell and like, look at what it's writing into the
file. Right? Yeah. Yeah, man. It's so, it's so helpful. Uh, once we had like the device that I'm
talking about, it was just getting, getting the shell dude was just unbelievably helpful. Like,
yep. And, and I know I did another interview with, um, one of the guys from Ponto owns in Synology.
And, um, you know, he talked about the importance of, to him of getting, you know, dynamic analysis on
these devices because he's specifically looking for RCE zero days. Um, yeah. And you know, you really have
to be able to get in there and sort of dynamically debug. It's just going to save you so much time.
Yeah. Um, so I think, I think depending on what kind of approach you have, there's a different,
there's a different route that you might take there. Um, but I definitely think for that exploit
development that is necessary. I would say it's necessary to get that to get. So it depends on
your goal. If you're looking for a zero day on the device firmware, that's good. But I think
oftentimes in a bug bounty context, we're just looking for maximum impact, right? So getting an
IDOR in the, the, the mother server of these IOT devices, right? Yeah. Um, uh, is actually way more
impactful because not only can we just pop this one device, we can pop all the devices potentially.
I like that. Um, okay. So I wanted to ask you this one as well. What does, you know, after,
after you're, you're on the device, you've got some, some, some grip on the device, whether it be
firmware, whether it be a dynamic shell, whatever, um, what kind of post exploitation attack vectors
do we need to think about there? Like you mentioned getting access to, you know, API keys or whatever,
so we can talk to the mother server. Um, what other things might, uh, web hackers and mobile hackers
that aren't thinking in this IOT hacking realm yet, not realize it is extremely important when
actually, you know, the rubber meets the road, you've got the firmware now it's volume time.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah, no, I w I would say, yeah, the, the attack surface is, yeah,
we've already talked about data in transit. We talked about network services. I would say within that
category of network services, right? You have the common network services that they're going to be
more used to the web based ones. And then there's going to be all this custom stuff that's going to
uh, lead them into binary reverse engineering and just to understand how the whole system works.
There's a lot of binary reverse engineering. You're very rarely going to find, uh, I say this,
uh, and I, and I know what you're going to think when I say this, you're very rarely going to find
Python on an IOT device. Yeah. Yeah. But sometimes there's an exception to every rule, right? Yeah.
I'm like, who puts that? Cause it's, it's slow. It's slow compared to C, right? And that's why
they don't do it. But maybe when you have a lot of resources on a system, it's fine. Um,
but the other thing that I'm looking at is again, thinking in that adjacent category, Bluetooth,
right? Bluetooth, wifi, any kind of RF, uh, that, that chips that are on the device, that there is code on
the device that will process that input and, and given output. So, so breaking this down,
you know, you're saying don't, don't necessarily just focus on the communication that, you know,
HTTP based oftentimes communication between the device and the, and the mother server, or, um,
just focusing on the web application. That's, that's being exposed on this device. Also look at these,
these more, these more binary level protocols and understand what function these play in the bigger
ecosystem of the device, right? And, and, and how to affect the business logic use cases of this
device via those protocols. Absolutely. And, and yeah, it's especially in those protocols where you will
find that the only security that is being implemented is, uh, security through obscurity,
right? It's, it's, it's just that, oh, this is a weird custom protocol or process or something like
that. And that's really what's providing the security to the systems. I've seen this so much too.
Like sometimes these things will literally just shell out, you know, to like, to like a binary
that's on the system and it's like, oh my gosh. So just diving deeper into, um, what's happening on
the backend of all these services and on, even on the web stuff, um, really, really impactful. And then
I think also sometimes there's like device to device, uh, communication that's happening. You know,
if you've got like an, uh, uh, you know, a mobile app that can also connect to this, you know,
Yeah. Diving into that mobile app and then understanding how that communication is happening,
Bluetooth or whatever. The other day I was literally, uh, testing an IoT device and I also
was listening to Spotify, which will scan your local network, which will broadcast across your local
network and look for UPnP services running on devices. And it was like contacting this IoT device
that I was looking at and I'm like, what the heck? Like Spotify, please stop that. Yeah.
But it's like, oh, okay. There's UPnP on this. So yeah, there, there, there is, uh, again,
in that local network context, you're right. So mobile app communications
to the device or device to device communications, if you have, uh, so, so for that, you want to think of,
if there's a company that has multiple devices that are in this ecosystem where they talk to each
other and they have all these cool integrations with each other, you might have to go buy another
device to, to observe there, there might be a code path that you will never actually see until you
possess this other device and put it on the same network. And then they all of a sudden start talking
to each other. I'll be explicit about this because it's, it's a well-known protocol that's way out there.
But, um, Amazon sidewalk protocol is really interesting because it essentially is trying
to replicate what they've done with, um, the, uh, find your iPhone, like, you know, network, essentially
of devices that have this device to device communication that provides very minimal data,
but will also allow you to just sort of identify your device wherever it is. Yeah.
And like, I was reading the spec for this thing and it's like, whoa, this is super weird. Um, because,
and there's a white paper out there, you can read the whole thing. They're very public about how this
is a secure protocol. Yeah. Um, but essentially it's allowing the, your phone that has no relationship
to this other device or, or whatever other device to send HTTP requests as a proxy through these Amazon
devices. I'm like, wow, this is like SSRF, you know, if I can figure out a way to get this to connect
to any host, this is really bad. Um, and, and obviously, you know, they've done their due diligence
trying to engineer it in a way that, that is, um, you know, more secure for that. But that was a real
eye opener for me as it, as it pertains to, um, device to device communication and what kind of
stuff they try to build into these, to create these seamless product experiences that we take for granted
in a lot of contexts, like, like the Spotify thing, right, where it's communicating with all the other,
you know, Google home devices that are like, you know, allowing me to control my Spotify from any
device in the house, you know, uh, you take that stuff for, for granted. But then when you start
assessing those sorts of products, it's like, oh, this is really sketchy. Yeah.
Another thing I want to mention, uh, talking about, yeah, strategy when I'm going after a device,
I think it was on your last podcast, you talked about the, the pros and the cons of like
the, the setup process or the initialization of an account and whether or not you should focus on
that. I will say in the IOT context, there are some bugs or there are some requests that will
only go out the first time the device ever is set up. Yeah. And there's a lot you can learn from that.
Uh, and, and like, like I, I found a device that even after factory reset, it would never again
send an HTTP request because it kept something in the firmware that persisted that some piece of
information in the firmware that persisted across factory reset. So I only caught the request using
my man in the middle router set up the first time the device ever connected to the internet.
That's cool. So, uh, but with IOT devices, another big, uh, maybe, maybe I'd call this an attack vector,
but the bootstrapping process, how does the device get its initial connection to the internet? Right?
So there's a lot of different choices that an IOT manufacturer here, we're considering a, like a
wifi based IOT device, right? So that device obviously needs some way to get your wifi, SSID,
and password so that it can connect to your network. And once it does that, it can talk to
its cloud servers and it's off to the races, but that bootstrapping process of how the device gets
added. And again, this is never going to be some remote exploit. This is going to be network adjacent
or physical or something like that, or local network. Um, some devices will spin up their own
wifi access point that then has like some API that you can then, that you then feed it the,
the SSID and password. And if you can jump on there and access some other API. Yeah. And like
services are exposed on that interface or something like that. It's like, Oh my gosh. Absolutely.
That's crazy. Or, or, or, you know, just, I mean, there's even the risk of, I mean, most devices are
moving away from that because it's a, it's almost a design flaw. I find, I find myself in IOT systems.
Uh, I don't know. I feel like I'm psychoanalyzing the developers of these IOT systems because I'll find
these bugs that I'm like, yeah, there's just no way to fix this unless you like scrap the project
because it's from the, from the design phase, they did something that necessitated, uh,
initially trusting something that is untrusted. Again, this bootstrapping process of how do I get
this device connected the first time another class of, uh, vulnerabilities that's like that
is squatting on a serial number. So let's say the device, once it connects to its cloud or its
mothership, right? Uh, it says, here's my serial number, please add me to this user's account.
Well, what's stopping me from just hitting that API and registering every, you know, sequential,
and then the serial numbers are usually sequential, right? And registering every device to my account.
And then when the actual user goes, it says this device error, this device is already registered,
right? And so denial of service and that. And wow. See that that's exactly what I'm talking about,
right? Like that, that is the sort of attack vector stuff that I love to hear on this podcast,
right? Like, like the stuff that you wouldn't necessarily, or you've, you've developed over
years of working on this stuff. That is, that is more specific to these hardware devices and the way
that they interact with all these services. Excellent. I love that. Um, what a cool idea.
And then also there's, there's also the, the, the resale approach to this as well. You know,
if you do a factory reset or whatever, I don't know if this is an accepted bug or not, but if you do a
factory reset on this device, right? And you sell it and then you are able to maintain a serial number,
a key or something like that, that then allows you to take over that device after somebody else has
used it again. Like, are those sort of bugs accepted or like, what are your, what's your experience?
I don't know about bug bounty programs accepting those findings. Um, I have definitely, uh, talked on
my YouTube channel at length because again, I get devices out of e-waste and then I, and then I present
them on my YouTube channel. And that is, uh, some of the occasional times where I need to
censor things in my video. I remember seeing that. Yeah. Because if I grab some device that's added,
yeah, like you can, again, we're talking about host APD, right? If I can get into that firmware
and find that host APD config file, it's going to have the SSID and the password in there or other
credentials and stuff like that. Yeah. I think you said, I think in one of the videos you said like,
yeah, guys, this is why we shred devices when we, when we get rid of them. Like, this is why you've never
resell the device. If you care about your security, because, um, here's this person's access key,
you know, or whatever. Yeah. There's a popular IOT device out there, which I won't name that if you
sell it on eBay, uh, others can buy it. And if you perform chip off and you go into that host APD file
and you, you find it's a society and password, then there's this attack vector where you using maybe
man in the middle router, you set up a wifi access point with that same SSID and password. Well,
now that device is going to happily connect and have internet access again. And what if that device
still has fresh tokens on it where, where that device now grants you access to somebody's account?
Oh my gosh. That may or may not be a thing out there. Who knows? Who knows? Um, I, I don't,
I don't know how in depth we'll go with this question, but if you've got anything on this,
great. If not, we'll move along. But, um, I wanted to ask, so like we talked about already on the pod,
a decent bit, um, these attacks, uh, that we're doing on IOT devices are often limited to adjacent
network or local, right? Um, let's say we've got a local device. Um, what are some ways that you have
been able to pivot this more into an adjacent or remote environment? Um, is there, I, I'm, I know it's
kind of a, a very product specific question. Um, and I think probably if I were to answer it myself,
what I would say is you have to have a thorough understanding of the application you're hacking,
um, to understand how to hit those code paths. But I'm wondering if you had any tricks up your
sleeve with regards to this, because things do get rated much lower, right?
They, they, they do. And that is unfortunate. Um, one thing I've, I've tried to do in the past with
mixed success, it, let's say I have a network service that maybe is intended only to be accessed
on the local network. And I, and I find a vulnerability in that, but I can prove through
using like Shodan or census IO that a bunch of people are port forwarding to this. And I actually
see real IOT devices of this manufacturer. And I like, so, so what I have to do then is find some
fingerprint that makes a good search, uh, on those platforms. And I can prove say, no, no,
there are actually remotely exploitable devices of this, of this type with this service that are on
the internet. And you know, several thousand of them sometimes. Yeah, I've definitely seen that.
And actually when you said that, it made me think about something. Um, I did hear at a talk recently
at RVASAC, the Richmond, uh, security conference talking about how a lot of these devices, you know,
have UFW or whatever set up for, you know, firewall on their WAN interface and you can't access all
these ports, but then on the IPv6 interface, they don't have any, any firewall, right? So you can
interact with all of these services that are just binded to, you know, star or whatever to every
interface, um, over IPv6 and, and get access to all of these internal services that are not listening on
the IPv4. Um, so I, I just, and, and apparently that was a massive trend. The guys that were
talking about it at the, um, uh, at the, the talk, they, they did a bunch of router exploitation and
they saw that a lot, which I was like, that is terrifying as we moved to IPv6, uh, what kind of
stuff we might run into with that. Yeah. Microsoft just had their big IPv6 bug. I don't know if we're
ready for it. Oh my gosh. I don't know, man. I, it's going to be, it's going to be a doozy for sure.
Yeah. Um, all right. Last one I had in this section was,
what is one area that you could grow in as a hardware hacker? What are you trying to grow in?
Oh yeah. That's a, like I mentioned before, it's microcontrollers and, uh, glitching. So
they're, uh, so I am not associated with them at all, but Hextry IO has some pretty sweet hardware
content coming out. And, uh, definitely when there's a lull in the action for me, I want to,
I want to start digging into that content because, um, again, like I said, in the microcontroller
context, that's, that's my weaker area as opposed to Linux based devices. And oftentimes a necessity
to extracting the firmware from those devices is, uh, glitching. Yeah. That makes sense. Yeah.
I think they were running, I think they're running a glitching workshop or something like that at,
at Defcon this year. They were, they were. Yeah. So bummed I didn't make it to that, man. Defcon is
such a difficult thing as a content creator as well, because you're, you're pulled in the direction of
producing, right? Like I want to give to the community at Defcon, but also there's such cool
shit going on, you know, like I want to just go and just sit in all these talks. And I was so salty
because, um, a couple of the talks that I really, really, really wanted to go to this year just had
hard conflicts with my own engagements. And I was like, so annoying. Um, okay. So let's go into some of
the more, um, advanced hardware stuff. Um, uh, we can, we can go to, to BGA reballing at some point,
but let's hit, um, the certificate pinning versus certificate validation section first and kind of
talk about, um, how, uh, cert minimum does, you know, uh, takes advantage of that whole situation
and, uh, what the differences between those two things are. Yeah. So to start off, I'm sure every,
uh, person who's looked at the scope of a bug bounty, uh, of a bug bounty program will see, uh,
that certificate pinning is out of scope on every program. And mostly, you know, this in the mobile
device context, but it's, it's, it's an identical situation in the IOT context. Right. And so, uh,
first we have to understand what the differences are because, and it's really hard to understand the
differences between cert pinning and SSL, like, like certificate validation, which is called that.
Um, because certificate pinning is just a stricter form of, uh, certificate validation. So if a device
is doing certificate validation, if they're actually checking that the, the, the server,
the server is presenting a certificate that is signed by a trusted CA in its trust chain, then,
but it's not pinning pinning, meaning it only trusts the leaf node, the server certificate,
not just any cert signed by a CA in its trust chain. Um, then that's fine. Like, like, that's not a
problem if they're not doing certificate pinning and not strictly saying, Hey, you have to have this
exact server certificate or a hash of it. There's different ways you can implement a certificate.
Pinning. But if they are doing neither of those, then that is a huge problem, right? It goes from
being NA to like, you know, high or critical, depending on the context, depending on what type
of information is being communicated in that TLS, uh, channel. Because specifically, if it's not doing
this validation correctly, you just have clear text access to everything that's happening through that
device. Exactly. And it should, again, there, this is where you sometimes have to argue with, uh,
triage and stuff like that. I think it's getting better because there's becoming more understanding
of these attacks, but, uh, understanding that that should be network that, that, that, that,
that is a remote, that is a remote attack because although oftentimes that attack is going to happen
on the local network on the same subnet through art poisoning, this is an inch or point or like having
control of the local router, any router along the path between the IOT device and the server
if any of those is compromised, right? So if you want to get crazy, you can go look at like some
of the like Snowden docs of like what the, one of the NSA programs alleged that they had the ability
on internet routers to perform man in the middle of TLS traffic. So if you think of a threat actor
like that, they don't need to be on your local network as long as they're along that path that the
data will take from the IOT device to the cloud server. Yeah. I mean, and think about when you're
using, um, you know, when, how many routers may be along the path in some of these public networks
you're connecting to as well. I mean, it's, it's a lot, it's a lot. Yeah. If you've run, if you run,
if you've ever run a trace route, you see how many routers, like it's what we're saying is that any one
of those routers, if they're compromised and can perform this man in the middle attack, then, uh,
that's very interesting. I wonder, so I wonder if that would be, I wonder what the trade-off is
between, uh, in CVSS between adjacent network and, or adjacent and network versus attack complexity high,
because you know, what, what I'll see them do sometimes is when you want to make these changes,
you'll, you'll do like, you'll flip one, uh, of the metrics and then add complexity high or whatever.
Yeah. I don't know where it stands on it. I, you know, and obviously I, I, I'm in, I, I'm with you,
you know, I think it should just be network without the attack complexity high because the risk is
there. But, um, yeah. Do, do you know where it stands? I kind of want to see.
Yeah. It's like, unfortunately I understand the attacks complexity high argument, but yeah,
I can't, I actually kind of understand that trade-off. I hate to say this because on the local
network, it's trivial, right? Right. Like if somebody is on the same subnet as you,
they can art poison and get themselves in a position of, of a man in the middle quite easily.
Uh, that is, that is pretty trivial. Whereas you could, you could argue, well, uh, having an attacker
have to compromise some internet router. That's that there is some complexity. So I'm looking at it now.
Yeah. What's the trade-off. Adjacent network
will give you an, in this specific scenario that I'm looking at a 1.1, uh, boost.
And then if you move attack complexity to high, that will drop you down way lower.
So it would, it would be better for you to have just adjacent network.
To be adjacent network with low.
Yeah. Then attack complexity high with network.
Well, I'll know what the R for.
By a couple points.
From now on.
Yeah. By, by 0.7.
Okay.
On the scale. Um, so, I mean, you're still landing within that high range. It's a high seven. The way that
I've got it is like, um, confidentiality high, uh, integrity low availability, none scope changed
user interaction, none privilege required, none. And then I'll switch the network in the attack
complexity fields. Um, and it looks like we're landing at like a 7.5, um, on the network attack
vector with attack complexity high. And if we switch it to adjacent network inside attack complexity
low, we're looking at an 8.2. So I think, I think, um, I think the best bet there is to go adjacent
network. Um, we're, we are bug bounty hunters right now. We are strategizing on what, what green
hat man, green hat all day. Let's go. Um, okay. So, so cool. So the important thing to understand here
is if you can find a problem with, um, the certificate validation at any, in any of the services
that are working on this, on this device calling back out, that could be a big problem. And, um,
and I think there's, there's more techniques, you know, obviously this, this really great talk by,
uh, oppo, right. Yeah. Is, is really great for that. But if there's more ways for us to sort of test
the implementation of, of TLS in this environment, um, that's great. I mean, that's, that's, you can
really pop some impactful bugs from that. You can. And, and, and yeah, when you're talking about
how that's going to get rated in my experience, it's always going to be based on what kind of data
is being transferred in that, right. If it's just your, if it's just your metrics, uh, log. Yeah.
Right. They're going to be like, no, no, that's not very, that's not, not very impactful. Right. But
if, uh, if there are session tokens in there, then that's an account take that, that is account
takeover, right. And then, and then, and then, and so that is going to be impactful. And so, um,
Yeah. And even if there is a tack complex or attack complexity high, or it's adjacent,
I've, I've had those be critical. Yeah. Be scored as critical if the data in there is really juicy.
Yeah. And you know, CVSS isn't necessarily built for that environment either. So I think
Yeah. Talking with the team, talking, understanding their threat model, this is important in any area
of bug bounty, but specifically in hardware stuff, that's important. Um, and yeah, you know, a high in,
uh, a high in the hardware world is like, you know what they say two birds in the high,
you know, I'm not even gonna try, but yeah, um, but yeah, you know, a high in the hardware world,
you know, is could pay as much as a crit in a, in the web world. So it can and more sometimes.
And something, uh, important to point out if you need ammunition for your reports, uh, hacker ones,
uh, I believe it's their platform standards. They have updated those to include man, uh, certificate
validation. And I think the default is a high, uh, really? Yes. That's really cool. So, so default
is a high depend and then, you know, various factors. So that's helpful if you need to include
that in your reports. That's really helpful, dude. Actually, I'm gonna look that up right now.
Certificate. I know. That's awesome. Yeah, they do have that. Wow. That's yeah, should be applied as a
high and they give you the CVSS 3.1 score. Very awesome, man. I love that. Thank you, hacker one.
Link that in your reports. Yeah, that one is going in the, in the description for sure.
Let me just go ahead and put that in there now so I don't forget. Um, perfect. Okay, great. So, um,
before we get on to the, uh, the hacking stories and such, which I'm really looking forward to,
let's hit this, um, this PGA reballing thing, man, because I am scared as heck of that. So,
essentially my understanding of that is you've, you've chip off, you've pulled the chip. Um, it's,
it's, it's a PGA and you've cleaned it all off, you know, gotten all the gunk off there,
plopped it into a reader, probably modify the chip in some way, right? Like replacing, you know,
inserting your own certificate as a certificate authority. Um, you know, maybe even, uh, added
something to the, the, the OS so that you can get a shell or something like that. Yep. And now you are
reattaching that device, you know, or that chip back to the device and then trying to boot the device
back up and have it use that chip. So bad. And you're hoping, you're hoping that praying
the light flash or whatever is the indicator that it's not completely borked. Yeah, right. Exactly.
Wow. That is just such a bad ass technique. Um, talk to me a little bit about that, how difficult
it is. And if you have any tips for it, you said you've done it a couple of times, right? Yeah. So
this is a new skill set that I'm developing. And, uh, that's why I say with this hardware hacking
stuff, like you can always hack on a device with less of the hardware hacking skills and then build
them out over time. You're just adding these tools, uh, to your tool, tool belt. So, uh, yes,
I've done it about three times successfully. I've ricked a ton of devices. I've, uh, you know,
pulled pads off, but yeah, effectively what we have is that's the word I was looking at that earlier.
So we have a PCB and it has, so, so PCB is made, uh, out of etch. It's etching copper. So there's a copper,
uh, like interface basically to the, to, to your PCB. And then it cuts out around the copper. It cuts
out copper so that you have all your connection points to where your different components connect
to the board. And so, yeah, so we're going to clean the, uh, the, uh, the pads on the chip and we're
going to clean the pads on the board. And then what we're going to do is you're going to use these BGA
And you're cleaning them with, uh, solder and, and some, a lot of flocks and you're trying to just
get those guys all pretty looking. And solder braid or wick. Okay. And so that's, that's just a metal
substance that are, you know, like, like that you, that you heat up and then the solder is attracted
to the braid and it takes it away from the PCB or your chip. Okay. Yeah. And when we're doing that,
we want to be careful not to pull off any of these pads, right? Cause these pads are connection points,
uh, from the chip to the board. And so there's pads on the chip that you could accidentally pull off
because you, because if the solder gets cold and then you pull on the braid, you're going to pull
off those, those, those little pads on the chips or the board. But if you pull them off, you're not
complete, you might not be screwed because on a hundred, like 153 is a pretty standard BGA.
There's ones with more, there's ones with like 200 pads and stuff like that. But on like a, a 153 BGA
chip, I think there's like 12 pads that are actually used all the other ones. When you look in the data
sheet, it'll say not, it'll say NC not connected or reserved for future use, which is effectively means
it's not connected now, but maybe someday they'll create a new EMMC standard and it will be connected.
Right. But most of them are not connected, which means on the PCB side, there are just floating,
floating, like there are just pieces of copper, copper circles where the chip connects that are
not connected to anything under the circuit board. Wow. So, so, so, but, but the ones that actually do
carry signals, they're going to go down under into the, uh, into the intermediate layers of the
PCB and connect to some electrical component, right? To the CPU or something like that.
The pads that are not connected to anything are way easier to pull off because of that.
There's less resistance, right? They're not, they're literally not connected to anything.
And so oftentimes, and it's funny when you look at the pin out for one of those BGA chips,
all the pins that are used are on one side. And one time I accidentally pulled off a ton of
pads from the other side. I'm like, oh, well I'm screwed. And then I go and I look at the,
at the pin out of the data sheet and I'm like, wait, no, I'm fine. Like I pulled off like 20 pads,
but I'm okay. You know, cause all the, cause all the ones that matter, the like, you know,
the 12 or so that matter were fine. And so.
That makes me feel so much better, dude. Like to, to know that out of like, you know,
this massive amount, there's like 12. All right. Just gotta get, there's only,
if I pull one off, there's only like a 10% chance that that is actually one that is necessary,
you know? Yeah. And it's even better than that because again, the ones that are easier to pull
off are the ones that you don't care about because because just because of the physics of how that
works. So, so, so when we clear that off, then what we want to do is we need to apply new solder balls
to the chip so that we can reattach it. And so I've got these stencil devices
that you lay the chip down in and then you lay the stencil, which is just a metal shield.
And then there's this solder paste. There's solder. That's in a paste form that you can spread
with a little squeegee, uh, almost like, you know, and so you fill in all the holes of the stencil that
perfectly sit on top of all 153, uh, pads. And then, uh, once you have enough that solder paste,
you just hit it with hot air for about 10 seconds and they all just, they, they, they turn into
perfect little solder balls. I love that. If, if you, if you did it right, if not, you have to take
it all off and start over again. But once you have those solder balls there, then you just put a light
amount of flux on the PCB, not too much because otherwise it can like swim off to the side when you
heat it up. Um, and, but you blast it with hot air and then it reattaches perfectly and then you boot it up
and yes, you cross your fingers and you hope that you didn't screw something up. Right. So, so when you're,
when you're, um, going back to chip off, when you're, when you're taking the chip off, um,
how, let me ask you this, how hot are you blasting it with air? Like, what do you normally set it to?
I think I have mine set to like 750 Fahrenheit.
Okay. Thank you, Joel. That's what I'm saying. Like, Joel was like, okay, so I actually made,
you know, I had a really funny meme in the, in the, um, in the presentation I did for Defcon where,
you know, I, I put up like a particularly like a younger picture of Joel. That's like,
he is looking really cool and he like had his hoodie up and he's like, looking like a hacker.
And, um, and I put a bunch of like little, uh, bubbles, you know, around his face, uh, thought,
thought bubbles or whatever. And he's like, don't, don't set your, your freaking hot air gun to like
700, Justin, you know, you're going to burn the chip. Don't pull the board off before it's ready.
Justin, you know, I bricked like three devices this time I was working with Joel on this.
Um, and, uh, and so I so appreciated his guidance with that, but man, you know, when you're using a,
a hotter hot, you know, a higher setting on that hot air gun, it just goes so much faster,
you know, with that. I mean, we, we probably sat there and, and, um, you know, went over the chip
for 20 minutes, you know, and, and, and I think he's correct in that, you know, you can burn,
burn up chips and you can cause problems, you know, with higher, higher, um, uh, settings and
stuff like that. But, uh, that, that's so gratifying for me to hear. I love that.
Justin Donaldson I am not a scientist. Let me, let me be clear. I'm an engineer. So like what
works is what I do, right? Maybe not like the technically correct way to do things like that.
That's, that's how I judge these methodologies.
Justin Donaldson When I said it's 700 goes so fast.
Justin Donaldson Yeah.
Justin Donaldson So that's why I do it.
Justin Donaldson That's great. I love that. So this is how you go from,
from breaking it open to firmware in an hour, huh? You don't spend an hour.
Justin Donaldson Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Justin Donaldson I don't got time to wait around for that.
Justin Donaldson Shooting it with hot air.
Justin Donaldson That's great, man. Well, that is an advanced technique, man. I, uh, I'm still a
little bit scared about that, but definitely more interested. I got to get myself some of that thread.
I actually don't have any of that, that, um, uh, you know, what is that the braided wire that you were using?
Justin Donaldson Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Justin Donaldson Yeah.
Justin Donaldson And, uh, I saw in your videos, you know, essentially you're just taking that
and you're putting the soldering iron on the backside of it and just kind of rubbing it over
those, those pads. Yeah. I think that that is really, really cool. We were trying to do something
Justin Donaldson That's something that takes practice. Cause that's where, that's where you're
likely to pull the pads off because you're, yeah, yeah, you're, you're, you're more likely to pull.
Justin Donaldson It's kind of odd using braids for that though, because I feel like braids have
more texture to them and would be more likely to like, if a corner of a pad is sort of like up a little bit,
you know, getting under it and like pulling it out. I don't know.
Justin Donaldson They, they, they, they are.
Justin Donaldson Yeah. Yeah.
Justin Donaldson All right. Very cool, man. Uh, well,
my favorite time of the episodes has come. Let's talk about some bugs. So, um, we've got missing
secure boot on a device and then, well, I won't, I won't spoil the second part. So take, take it away
with this, uh, this bug that you've prepared for us.
Justin Donaldson So yeah. Uh, yeah. So can't talk about the name of the device or anything like that,
but it was a, it was a microcontroller based device. Okay.
Justin Donaldson Okay. Nice.
Justin Donaldson It is usually the device that I'm not as good at targeting, but I think this story
actually illustrates my point that even if you can't completely understand the firmware or something
like that, you can still get something out of it. Right? Like all these tools of hardware hacking,
they help you solve a problem. They help you find vulnerabilities. You don't need to have all of them
at once. So, uh, so on this microcontroller device, I, you know, probably the first thing I did was look
for you are nothing, you know, like, uh, look where you are J J tag enabled. None of that's going to
work, but it did have an external flash chip. So I didn't have to go. It wasn't going to have to do
any glitching to extract the firmware. So, uh, this was one of these really easy, like eight pin. I think
one of the models of device had a 16 pin chip, but pretty easy to remove and put back on the board.
So I removed it, read the firmware out ran bin walk. So this is a microcontroller firmware. It's just a,
it's just a binary blob of data. And so there's no file systems to extract, but what bin walk did
identify in it are a few certificates. And I had already been looking at the network traffic.
Oh, that, that I saw from the device. I tried some, I tried a man in the middle attack. So I tried using
man in the middle proxy, which, uh, so this is before I was using certain minimum, I might've found,
I might've found a vulnerable, I might've found part two of this explanation a lot faster if I
would have been using certain minimum. So that's a good advertisement for it, but I was using man in
the middle proxy. So the way that man in the middle proxy works by default is it has its server
certificate has a CN. The common name is man in the middle proxy. So, uh, or man in the middle proxy CA or
something like that. Right. And so then it signs, it forges certificates. So let's say the traffic
that is trying to intercept is going to www.example.com. Then it's going to forge a certificate
with the server certificate is going to have the CN of www.example.com. And then it's going to sign it
with the man in the middle proxy CA. Right. And then it's going to present that to the client and see if
the client takes the bait. Right. Um, and in this case, the device was not taking that, that form of
bait. So, uh, so then what I did is, uh, yeah, so chip off the, and read the firmware. And I found
that there's, there are these certificates, they were in the DER format, which is a binary encoding.
It's not like the pen file where you see a bunch of basic 64 encoded stuff. It's completely a binary
protocol, uh, or a file format. And then I was like, you know what? Okay. That's the CA.
Yeah. So I'm like, I need to generate a certificate that has exactly as many bytes as this other
certificate. So I need a byte for byte. Oh my God. Duplicate of the certificate, but my key,
but I need my key to be in there. Right. So I, you know, I, I worked with open SSL for a while and all
the weird options that I needed to set to get it exactly the correct number of bytes. Oh my gosh.
And so then I took the firmware and I knew the offset of their D their, uh, DER certificate. So
I just, you use the, the DD command and like some of the arguments there. Oh yeah. They have that in,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So in DD, you can say, uh, block size BS equals one. And then, so then you're doing things, uh,
one bite at a time. You're dealing with bites, uh, as the block size, and then you can say skip.
So you can skip a certain number of bites and then you can say size. So size says how many
bites you'll copy from the source to the destination. So I caught, I just very carefully,
uh, I think in my, I think when I presented this finding, I had the, uh, Indiana Jones meme of like,
like placing in, I'm just very carefully seeing if this cert, I can, I can place the cert right in
place of the other one, right? Exactly. Um, and so, uh, I did that. I, and then I had my,
and so then I had a new firmware image and I flashed that back to the chip, soldered it back onto the
board, booted it up. And now man in the middle proxy can intercept the SSL traffic. So, uh, not all
IOT devices, uh, or manufacturers care about or having their threat model secure boot, but this,
this company did care very much about that. And they called this a high because I effectively proved
that I was able to get modified firmware to boot successfully. Yeah. Uh, by the chip, by the micro
like I said earlier, you know, grub and like anything boot related is like not my shit. Like I, I do not
like that at all. Um, and so can you talk to me a little bit about what that process was like?
You know, I, I, I'm, I'm tracking with you, you know, you pull the blob out. Um, obviously this is a,
uh, a microcontroller system, so it's a little bit different than the way I'm thinking about it
probably. But you know, you, you figure out, you've been walking, you figure out the offsets,
you overwrite the cert. I'm tracking with you there. Writing it back onto that chip is something
that I've never done. I mean, are you just doing, how are you doing that? Is that a part of the
Yeah. So this is going to be a difference between the way that EMMC readers work.
Yeah. Cause they just kind of mount as a file system on your computer. Right.
But the ex GECU, uh, that universal programmer that I use your, when you do a read,
you do a read of the whole firmware image on the chip and you get an image back one image of the
full length of the chip of everything that's stored on there. So then all I was doing is I was taking
that firmware image, modifying my one little piece with the certificate, and then going back into
that software. Again, it's not as direct as when you're, when you're doing things on with EMMC, you,
you go back into the software and you, you know, upload the file from your computer, the modified image,
and then you do a right operation back to the chip. So it's all through the universal programmer.
In the MMC side, if you've got it just mounted like an SD card, you can just, you can just modify
it in that file system and then just pull it out and, you know, slap it back on the device.
If in that scenario. Yes. Yes. You would be able to do that. Yeah. You, you mount it, uh, read,
write and you, yeah, that would totally work. Wow. That's, that's crazy, man. Yeah. And then I
guess it's up to the... And if there was Secureboot... Yeah. How does Secureboot come in?
...that would get in the way of that. Right. Um, and, and Secureboot definitions differ across,
you know, manufacturers and stuff like that. But in the context of a microcontroller, right?
That, that certificate I was modifying it, like I wasn't modifying a part of the file system. I was
modifying code, right? Yeah. Like, like that certificate was embedded in probably in like a C
program that then got compiled for this microcontroller and loaded into flash. And basically by,
by me modifying it and getting it to boot and operate just normally, right? Uh, well, except, you know, with,
trusting my, my certificate instead of the other one, I was, I was able to prove by doing that,
that was like a way for me to prove that there was no validation of the firmware happening. And then,
I mean, they confirmed that on their side. So what, what they need to be doing is some sort of like,
check on the actual binary that is the firmware in these microcontrollers. And where would you even
do that check from also, maybe they should have done a check on the actual certificate itself and
said, you know, in somewhere else in the code said, Hey, has this certificate been tampered with?
I don't know how would they even fix that? Yeah. So, so the typical way that secure boot
is implemented is this is the actual microcontroller or the CPU will have some very small internal storage
where you can program in, you can burn in a PR a public key. And then you who are developed or the
firmware developer have that corresponding private key and you will sign the firmware, uh, with the
private key such that a person with the public key can either CPU or the microcontroller can, can perform
that check and it will halt the CPU if, if it, if the signature doesn't validate. Gotcha. Wow.
That's, that's pretty freaking cool, dude. Okay. So you're, you're able to, to modify this, uh,
microcontroller based firmware, a binary blob. Yup. You did it specifically within these offsets. You
got a cert that would just create that at that length and that exact size inserted it in there,
fire it back up, man. I can't imagine the rush of being able to see that traffic, you know? Oh my gosh,
that must've been amazing. Um, and then where do you go from there? Yeah. So this is a funny part of
this story of how I stumbled even into a larger, a more critical vulnerability. Uh, so, okay. So I
should know that that mot that new, you know, my firmware modified CA certificate that I generated,
I didn't put the man in the middle proxy certificate in there. I created one again, I wanted it to be
exactly like the existing one. So I created a new self-signed cert that was the same common name,
the CN of whatever CA they were using. I, I don't remember the name of it, but, um, they're using
some kind of certificate authority. It was probably an internal company, certificate authority. And so I,
I just kept that, that name exactly the same. So literally the only difference between my certificate
and theirs was, was the, the key was the public key portion of this certificate. This is actually kind
of like the implementation of this, a certain minimum attack. And a lot of, yeah, that's one
of those attacks. I stumbled into, yeah, exactly. And that's why I say a certain minimum would have
caught what I found next. Yeah. And that is that, okay. So if the device was a hundred percent doing
certificate validation, the correct way, then my within this new modified state, the device would only trust
my fake CA certificate, not the real one from the, from the real server. Right. So I had to keep my
man in the middle setup running in theory for the device to be operational. Well, I was like doing
something, I had some, you know, problem with my computer. Um, it was probably the only time Arch
Linux ever had a problem. Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You know, you never have to reboot that. Never. Um, but I
rebooted and I like forgot to set up my man in the middle setup again. And I turned the device on and then I
had this realization of like, Oh, I forgot to put my man in the middle, uh, you know, set up in there.
The device probably isn't working now because it doesn't trust the certificate on the server and
it's modified state. And then I like checked with the mobile app or some way, you know, and I'm like,
Oh, it's working. Oh, like, and then I'm like, like there's at this point, I'm like, there is
something terribly wrong with, with the device firmware. And so, so yeah, so I affect that. You're right.
I effectively performed the cert minimum attack where I created a, a CA only. I put it on the
device, not, not, not in the man in the middle proxy where, uh, it had the same exact, uh, where
I wasn't just faking. I wasn't just faking the server. I was faking the CA and the server. Right.
Right. And it turns out that on this device, what it was doing, what it was programmed to do
was programmed to check when, when it was, when the client connected to the TLS server and it got
the server back, the only thing it was checking in that certificate was that the, the CA who signed
that certificate had the CN equals to whatever string. Oh my God. It expected. What the heck.
And so, so anyone obviously can craft a self-signed certificate with that value in there and perform
a man in the middle. And this led to account takeover because there were, you know, I mean,
it was like the devices, like all the devices communications, which included its authentication
credentials were in that TLS. You know, I wonder if this type of attack is more common
on microcontroller based devices because they're not relying on, you know, I say these battle tested
libraries, there's like a ton of CVs that dropped with the certain minimum thing of like every, uh,
TLS validation software out there had a CV, but you know, they're not using these more trusted methods
of doing that. They're, they're often optimizing for size because those things, the storage on those
devices are much smaller. Um, so I wonder if they're, they're cutting corners on, on TLS implement,
uh, you're a hundred percent right. And so, so oftentimes when you get a certain brand or a certain
type of microcontroller, you will be provided with an SDK that will include utilities for making,
web requests, like, you know, connecting to Watt to wifi. Um, and so, yeah, they will,
there will be a, a, a diversity of functionality. Whereas when it's a Linux device, if it's, if it's,
you know, connecting to wifi, it's like, yeah, it's going to use WPA supplicant. It's going to act
the same way every time. Right. Or when it's making a web request, it's like, oh, they're probably
using lib curl or, you know, some common library. Right. Uh, that is battle tested. Yeah. You see a bunch
more sketchy shit and I, IOT hacking stuff, which is really fun. I think that's one of the things
that's really exciting about it too. Um, so, all right, man, we've done it. We've made it through
the whole doc. Thank you so much for doing this. This was a, uh, really eyeopening talk on, on
IOT hacking stuff. Um, yeah, I'm definitely reemboldened to go after IOT hacking targets
once, uh, when I can get my hands on a program to do that. Um, so thank you so much, man.
Thanks for having me on. Of course. And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for listening. And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to
ctbb.show slash discord, join the discord. There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over
there. And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access to
masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us. We'll see you there.